Justin and Selena are still hanging out
but are they more than friends plus
inside Game six of the World Series
hello friends how we doing it is an
exciting day in Los Angeles today the
World Series is tied and tonight the
Dodgers take on the Houston Astros for
the title I was lucky enough to be at
game six which will have for you in just
a few but first oh my god Justin Bieber
and Selena Gomez boy do these two have a
way of finding each other rumors have
been swirling that Jelena is back
together since Selena split from the
weekend and these latest photos are
adding fuel to that fire the two were
snapped all smiles today as they rode
bikes together I mean just look at these
two biking around without a care in the
world people and at one point Selena
adorably arrests her head on Justin's
shoulder while walking on the sidewalk
it looks like their arms are also linked
together and I'm thinking Jelena is real
but are they actually more than friends
right now I don't know because Gomez was
also photographed riding a bike
yesterday in her ex's track jacket
that's right the weekend has been
spotted wearing the same distinctive zip
up before still Justin and Selena have
been spending a lot of time together
lately and let me catch you up on their
recent rendezvous and July Biebs
canceled his tour and reconnected with
Selena after her kidney transplant then
the two reunited at Selena's home last
weekend a source told ET they were
hanging with a bunch of other friends
it's totally platonic they claimed on
Monday ET learned that Selena and The
Weeknd called it quits after ten months
of dating just a day after Justin and
Selena were spotted having breakfast
together are you following me now
neither have yet to confirm whether
they're a couple or just close pals and
a source told et on Monday that Selena
never stopped caring for Justin but
added quote selena and Justin won't do
anything that would jeopardize their
friendship not just between them but
between their whole group of friends so
don't expect them to jump into anything
too quickly and if they did I'm not sure
everyone would be too pleased about it
because our source also says Selena's
friends and family haven't been as
patient and forgiving with Bieber as
Selena has now a source tells ET Selena
and Justin aren't officially a couple
but seem to be moving in that
rection and as that things might be
different this time quote this version
of justin is exactly the type of guy she
always wanted to be with and the type of
guy she always knew he was deep down oh
that is a lot to unpack people but I
want to know what you guys think should
you Lena get back together is this like
a Miley liamri up or should it be just
in Brittany and just stay in the past
let us know in the comments alright now
that I've caught you guys up on the
juicy are they are aren't they gossip
it's time to talk baseball your boy got
to attend Game six of the World Series
and I've never been this excited about
sports since Beyonce performed at Super
Bowl halftime people all right today I'm
taking you inside all the excitement
down at Dodger Stadium hey what's up you
guys if you can believe it I made it to
the World Series baby this is my home
town team you guys where I gave 6
Dodgers vs. Astros and if you've been
following along it has been an
absolutely friggin nutty series who
knows what's gonna happen today but I'll
tell you one thing we're gonna stick
around to find out so let's play ball
[Music]
are you guys I'm kind of freaking out
because I'm in the Dodger dugout I don't
know who let me in but I mistake listen
the last time the Dodgers were in the
World Series was 1988 so this is a big
deal the town is hype the celebs are so
excited to be here but you know who's
losing their minds right now the fans
let's go find them this is a big door
explain to people out there why this is
such a big big deal for our town world
series we're the greatest city in the
nation describe it is the hottest ticket
in town
how much you guys pay for these go away
come on we got enough how excited are
you guys for this game is that what
you're drinking you're right we want to
remember the game we don't know them we
don't know them all right that's enough
of that
stop that that's commitment man yo that
is some commitment right there you go
how long did it take you to put this
face together about an hour hour 15 and
have you been like that every game I did
it every season all season long home
game you know you're the reason why
we're here know exactly we gotta get
this how special is it to be here right
now game six World Series Dodgers
I mean I'm possibly getting fired from
work house question do you think that is
you know what's got fired boy I might
get fired tonight I'm great they can't
tell who you are right that's right man
you just shout out go Dodgers people
will cheer wait for it wait for it
gotta get the right crowd though see the
trick is you gotta find the right people
let's go Dodgers Dodgers in seven go
Dodgers I'll be heading back there
tonight for the final game and of course
sending out the positive vibes for our
Dodgers but either way what a series of
thin I'll have more of that for you guys
tomorrow so be sure to ring the bell so
you don't miss the daily Denny and I'll
see you guys tomorrow
[Applause]